We’re constantly trying to find evidence
of life on other planets, but have we been
going about the search all wrong?
Hey guys, Amy here with DNews.
The desire to find life on other worlds is
a very strong one that has basically dictated
how we’ve gone about unmanned space exploration
since we started shooting robots off the Earth.
We know that life here requires water, so
NASA’s maxim when it comes to space exploration
is “follow the water.”
We’ve looked for evidence of a wet past
on Mars, we focus on subsurface oceans of
distant moons like Jupiter’s Europa, and
we search for exoplanets in the goldilocks
zone, that is, planets that orbit their stars
where liquid water can exist on their surface.
But what if we should be approaching this
differently?
Some scientists have already suggested that
we broaden the “goldilocks zone” to take
into account a host star’s evolution and
how its cooling could have changed the timeframe
in which liquid water existed on a planet’s
surface.
This is something we’ve talked about on
DNews before: the idea that water could have
existed on a planet in its early life when
its star was hotter even if that planet is
now too far from its star and too cold for
water.
We might do well to take some extraterrestrial
life hunting tips from isotopes.
Recently, scientists at the University of
Surrey, Japan's RIKEN Nishina Centre, and
the University of Beihang recreated in a lab
the isotopes that occur when a star explodes.
It wasn’t just for fun; it was an attempt
to help physicists understand where life-supporting
elements might be found in space, something
that by extension could give us some clues
on where to look for signs of life.
The team was able to observe isotopes of certain
elemental chemicals that form when a star
explodes.
To get these isotopes, the team accelerated
uranium to 70 percent of the speed of light
and smashed it into a metal target.
Then, they analyzed the fragments left behind
by the impact using a gamma-ray microscope,
specifically isotopes of samarium and gadolinium,
both of which are sensitive tracers of an
exploding star that could help explain where
the heavy elements that support life in our
universe originate.
What’s really neat is that these exotic
isotopes aren’t ones scientists have had
a chance to study before, so their existence
in the wake of a violent event opens an interesting
path for the potential creation of the elements
essential for life as we know it.
It really is true that star dust -- the remnants
of exploded stars -- plays a vital but mysterious
role in the formation of life-supporting planets.
There’s still a lot we need to learn, but
this is a really neat development.
What do you guy think about our ongoing quest
to find life on other planets and moons?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.